listen okay tonight is did you fly here
last week yes how has the reaction been
to your second coming of sexiness with
this new look it's everywhere on the
internet anyway what's the reaction been
how have you felt about all of this like
I mean is so sexy I loved it because it
was a whim you know New Year's Eve my
family said try it just shave it and I
took a picture and I dared to reveal it
with my daughter on the Internet I had
never expected there would be such
approval of that but yeah I'm happy you
got a love fan suntan thank you
obviously tonight's all about Australia
this has been sort of intertwined
throughout your career starting with
your favorite probably Australian Olivia
newton-john and I know that she hasn't
been well have you talked to her how is
she actually from what I hear targeter
she's fine and I think she even made a
public announcement in her own video
that she was fine and you know that
happens people may misinterpret or fear
if you don't communicate sometimes it
becomes a mystery or something but she's
fine and tell me what is your secret to
a long-haul flight to Australia you
bring a snack flight to Australia no
when you take Qantas just show you're
taking care of the whole way from on
every level you know even the science of
flight is used on those long now there's
a new flight from Perth to London and
they've that the lighting right they've
got the cuisine right where it's the
least distress for but they got it all
going it's awesome
thank you for coming thank you
[Music]